attention vous entrez dans un monde sans
mensonge à la [ __ ] y'a flic c'est
pourquoi je vous arrête parce que ça
fait trois plombes que vous jetez les
couilles sur le bord de la route et du
coup vous arrêtez tout le monde pour
faire votre quota qui n'ont pas les
papiers et les ics est permis de
conduire totino ans [ __ ] la gueule
c'est quoi ça c'est un nouveau système
de vérification des permis
non pas du tout dangereux et son
collègue puisqu'on fait concours de la
plus belle gueule de con à l'applaudir
avec ça vous êtes sur podium a lieu le
concept pas mal non plus offre aux
valeurs ada vous a flashé 47 km 1 cuil
ah non pas cool c'est une zone 30 on a
planqué le panneau juste derrière
l'arbre ring pour munich et annecy est
vrai alors un point et 135 euros
oui oui c'est maman mais je te rappel
après attendait téléphone au volant
allez hop 8 à trois points et 135 euros
autre chose j'ai pas mon village est pas
mon triangle et j'ai grillé un feu rouge
non le grand chelem a alors là on est
sur un total de 540 euros et wii points
je vous remercie parce qu'elle écoute
j'ai explosé mon record la prenaient du
plaisir à faire c'est un peu mon nom
parce que moi je vais faire bruce willis
comme et qui bat julie lescaut toute
façon sans votre unis fin on fait moins
le malin
abbas était jusqu'à la baraque c'est ma
femme qui porte la culotte alors moi dès
que je peux avoir cinq minutes
d'autorité de gens profitent et les
peurs à l'année et rouler doucement
enfin pour vous ce que dis je vais
tourner et j'ai roulé comme un [ __ ] là
vous allez freiner quand tu auras un
radar à l'accélérer juste derrière exact
mais on arrive quand même encore aboli
qui n est qu un radar mobile
je sais bon allez bonne journée elle est
bien vous faire [ __ ] par aimant
[Musique]